Carrusel de las artes
[Música]
María Carolina piña
Carrusel de las artes se encuentra en el
festival Beatriz América Latina que este
año tiene un invitado de lujo el padre
de uno de los personajes más conocidos
de la literatura contemporánea Mario
Conde protagonista de varias novelas
policiales y de una novela en particular
que marcó un hito el hombre que amaba
los perros tenemos como invitado hoy en
nuestro programa al escritor cubano
Leonardo padura Cómo está Leonardo Muy
bien gracias gracias por la invitación
pues muchísimas gracias a ustedes estar
con nosotros en nuestro programa que
recibe las artes Leonardo se ha hecho
hoy un baño de multitudes aquí en el
festival de biarritz mucha gente que
quería verlo y nosotros queríamos
hacerle esta invitación para hablar de
ese último libro que fue publicado aquí
en francés en Francia agua por todas
partes vivir y escribir en Cuba por la
editorial metelier es un libro distinto
porque es un conjunto de crónicas que
usted ha describiendo durante varios
años y comienza o la excusa de ese libro
es una pregunta que nosotros los
periodistas le hemos hecho en
innumerables ocasiones y es porque sigue
viviendo y trabajando en Cuba cuál es la
respuesta es interrogante por la
respuesta hay muchas respuestas hay una
muy cortita porque soy cubano una un
poco más larga porque soy un cubano que
escribe en Cuba quiere escribir sobre
Cuba tiene un fuerte sentido de
pertenencia Cuba y porque creo que las
cosas no se resuelven si todo el mundo
se va tiene que haber alguien por lo
menos que sea testigo y las cuente y un
poco a veces ha sido mi propósito en
estos años escribir sobre la realidad
cubana con el personaje que tú mencionas
con Mario Conde de alguna forma he
tratado de hacer una crónica de la vida
cubana contemporánea desde la
perspectiva de mi generación y la
cercanía a esa realidad es buena medida
la que me permite hacer ese ejercicio
literario y ahora el título de este
libro agua partes está tomado de un
verso de Virgilio Piñera la
circunstancia del agua por todas partes
usted dice que esa condición insular es
muy importante para los cubanos porque
ser una isla porque él está rodeado del
mar es tan tan fundamental para los
cubanos
toda la grandeza problemas las
desgracias las buenaventuras que ha
vivido Cuba le han llegado por el mar y
el hecho de estar en ese territorio
limitado por por agua por todas partes
como quien dice Virgilio que él lo
consideraba una circunstancia
Pues condiciona muchas maneras de pensar
de sentir y toda esa sensación de vivir
un poco aislados del mundo que se ha
acentuado en determinados momentos Pues
también influye en en una espiritualidad
como la cubana pero ese sentimiento de
la insularidad yo creo que que muchas
veces incluso Acompaña a esos cubanos
que viven fuera de La Isla porque es
esencial en la manera de entender en la
espiritualidad cubana es un como un
cordón umbilical Sí yo creo que que la
pertenencia está relacionada con el
territorio y el territorio está rodeado
de aguas por todas partes y ahora que
usted nombra que utiliza esa palabra la
pertenencia es algo que usted explica
nos Explica en este libro sentirse
pertenecer a Cuba y no sólo a Cuba sino
a la Habana y eso no no solo a la Habana
sino al barrio de mantilla de donde
usted nació y donde sigue viviendo Por
qué ese lugar es tan importante para
usted es el lugar del inicio de todo y
no solo del inicio es el lugar donde ha
ocurrido casi todo Yo soy de esas raras
especies de personas en esta época del
mundo que vive en la misma casa donde
nació eso me arraiga mucho a ese lugar
en esa casa tengo todavía
afortunadamente a mi madre mi recuerdo
mis libros
toda mi formación como personas se
produjo allí en ese lugar
donde además vivió mi padre Mi abuelo mi
bisabuelo de los paduras varias
generaciones y tengo un arraigo y un
sentido de pertenencia muy fuerte este
barrio que es un barrio bastante feo
últimamente bastante deteriorado pero
que es mi lugar en el mundo mi principal
lugar en el mundo se llama mantilla Ahí
está y hablar de Cuba y de los cubanos Y
retratar esa realidad a través de la
literatura es también retratar o relatar
la resignación de los cubanos la
frustración la marginalidad usted lo
dice en su libro es para usted usted lo
dice en esta Crónica una terrible misión
que usted ha aceptado no creo que sea
terrible creo que es unas palabras bueno
esto a lo mejor exageré un poquito ahí
al decir eso no es una es una misión que
yo no pedí pero que he aceptado el hecho
de tener la posibilidad de la expresión
de la palabra y de que esa palabra sea
empresa y sea divulgada creo que me da
me confiere
la responsabilidad y que yo asumo desde
una perspectiva civil creo que como
ciudadanos tengo las obligación el
derecho la necesidad a expresar todas
esas frustraciones esperanzas sueños
deseos maldiciones y bendiciones que
rodean a los cubanos en la medida de mis
posibilidades porque no quiero resultar
pretencioso lo que digo no es que yo
escriba a Cuba es que yo escribo sobre
Cuba y escribo lo mejor que puedo sobre
lo que puedo como puedo porque siempre
hay límites de conocimiento de capacidad
de talento Pero bueno yo hago mi mejor
esfuerzo y siempre digo que cada uno de
los libros que yo he escrito es el mejor
libro que he sido capaz de escribir en
el momento que lo he escrito y si no es
mejor no ha sido por falta de esfuerzo
ha sido por falta de talento el esfuerzo
siempre ha estado bueno y hay una
crónica muy sabrosa de leer que es con
respecto al reggaetón usted nos habla
del reggaeton y nos hace pensar
efectivamente que Cuba ha sido una isla
musical es un país de música por
excelencia y cómo se implantado ese
reggaeton allí que usted no lo describe
con un de muy buena manera no no le
gusta mucho el reggaetón ocurre esto es
un fenómeno caribeño es un fenómeno de
todo el área del Caribe Y de pronto en
un territorio de tanta riqueza Que
aparezca un fenómeno musical como el
reggaeton que tenga la tentación que
tiene que además haya tenido larga vida
que ya va teniendo es un fenómeno
bastante asombroso Porque si en lo
musical es bastante limitado a veces en
la parte lírica sus letras sus versos
pueden tener una determinada calidad
pero a veces está muy lejos de cualquier
calidad posible entonces resulta un poco
extraño que haya ocurrido ese fenómeno
Pero bueno el resultado de una evolución
de una generación es que se expresan de
una determinada forma y siempre tengo
mucho miedo a la hora de juzgar
determinados procesos de cualquier tipo
pero en el caso de los artísticos
especialmente porque a partir de los
gustos de uno uno puede prejuiciarse
demasiado al juzgar determinados
acontecimientos movimientos actitudes
respecto al arte entonces uno debe ser
cuidadoso pero también la opinión es la
opinión y mi opinión es que es como una
degradación de toda esa riqueza cultural
que a través de la música ha expresado
El Caribe a lo largo de varios siglos y
se puede escribir escuchando reggaeton
todo el día el reggaeton del vecino
no se puede escribir oyendo reggaeton no
eso no
Leonardo hace poco más de un año se
produjo en su país una protesta muy
amplia contra el gobierno de Cuba esa
explosión tuvo mucha repercusión no más
en Cuba sino también en el exterior para
ustedes eso es un fenómeno que también
puede ser materia para sus por supuesto
yo creo que cualquiera acontecimiento
No lo sé porque no lo ha intentado en
una novela creo que que en algún momento
por ejemplo en mi libro más reciente el
anterior el último libro como Polvo en
el viento se habla de unas protestas que
ocurrieron en el año 1994 en Cuba
ocurrieron fundamentalmente en la zona
de La Habana alrededor del Malecón Y de
esa agua por todas partes muy visible en
el muro del Malecón y hablo de esas de
esas protestas creo que en algún momento
puede que afloren en mis libros es un
acontecimiento que que ha marcado la
historia contemporánea de Cuba la más
reciente y creo que sí que perfectamente
es una materia novelable
en estos momentos todavía no estoy
pensando una nueva novela he terminado
muy cansado la novela anterior y
entonces cuando yo termino un libro
prefiero darme un tiempo antes de
empezar otro la experiencia me dice si
empiezo a escribir muy cerca un libro de
otro de alguna manera sigo escribiendo
el libro anterior entonces me tomo me
tomo un tiempo y lo que hago
Generalmente es que preparo un libro
como agua por todas partes escribo algún
ensayo escribo para el cine doy un curso
doy conferencia y trato de darme un
tiempo antes de entrar en otra en otra
historia y ahora mismo tengo dos o tres
esbozos muy primarios muy primarios de
ideas que no sé de qué forma lo voy a
escribir pero ya me lo plantearé en su
momento Bueno pero eso es una promesa de
que seguirá no no voy a seguir
escribiendo Mira yo necesito escribir a
ver Tengo un amigo escritor que que me
dijo un día bueno en cualquier momento
me voy a jubilar y me dijo me voy a
jubilar y me cuenta que después el día
que se jubilaba se levantó por la mañana
se tomó un café
leyó los periódicos esto miró por la
ventana y dijo Bueno qué hago ahora y se
sentó y se puso a escribir otra vez creo
que los escritores En la jubilación muy
difícilmente nos corresponda bueno con
esa Promesa de que usted no se va a
jubilar por habernos por ahora
terminamos esta entrevista
agradeciéndole Leonardo padura a haber
estado con nosotros muchísimas gracias y
bueno nosotros Seguimos aquí en el
festival viernes América Latina y vamos
a mostrarles ahora los principales
premios de la competencia
cinematográfica
[Música]
en el Mundo perfecto mío
el que no quiera
no existe Colombia se llevó el premio el
abrazo al mejor largometraje por la
cinta Los reyes del mundo de Laura Mora
la película relata la historia de rap un
muchacho de la calle que emprende con
sus amigos un viaje de Medellín al bajo
cauca para recuperar las tierras que le
fueron robadas a su abuela una
desplazada del conflicto armado Laura
Mora no pudo estar en la premiación pero
Carrusel de las artes había conversado
con ella sobre los reconocimientos que
ha recibido su película para mí
definitivamente el arte en general El
buen arte Debería ser político y con eso
no quiero decir militante y a mí me
atraviesa mucho la obsesión sobre la
justicia desde esos premios son una
posibilidad de que se vea la película de
que la película pueda viajar más y pueda
tener un diálogo más amplio con el
público en el mundo
estamos muy emocionados pero yo todavía
no me lo creo mucho extorsión secuestro
robo de material clasificado viendo
laburones
el premio del Jurado fue para una
comedia negra Argentina punto rojo de
nicanor loretti quien hizo reír al
público con esta cinta que mezcla
Thriller mucha creatividad visual y
Pasión por el fútbol sexto la verdad que
Fue increíble verla con el público de
biarritz porque es un gran público mucha
gente va a ver todas las películas una
sala enorme siendo una película
subtitulada de humor donde hay humor
negro y la reacción las risas del
público con el humor fue muy
gratificante la verdad el Jurado
presidido por el director francés
Enrique plástico se felicitó por la
fuerza del cine latinoamericano
lo que más nos emocionó a todos en el
Jurado es ese espíritu desesperado al
mismo tiempo libre del cine en
latinoamericano Vimos a una América
Latina que sigue estando conmocionada y
al mismo tiempo que es súper potente
[Música]
terminamos este Carrusel de las artes
con el grupo brasileño asimite en
concierto aquí en el festival Beatriz
América Latina Muchísimas gracias por su
sintonía y hasta la próxima Bye
[Música]